سنتوقف ايضا مع هذه الصور من جورجيا هناك
اشتباكات بين قوات الامن وبين متظاهرين في
جورجيا طبعا بسبب هذا القانون المثير
للجدل حول الاعلام وبعض المنظمات هذه
التظاهرات ايضا
يبدو بانهم يحاولون اقتحام مقر البرلمان
هذه الصور نتابعها
ويبدو بان الشرطه ايضا تطالبهم باخلاء
المنطقه اذا هذه التظاهرات في جورجيا
متظاهرون يحاولون اقتحام البرلمان الشرطه
تطالبهم بان يبتعدوا وهذه التظاهرات
مستمره منذ ايام وهي بسبب
قانون او رفضهم لقانون
مثير الاثار الجدل حول الاعلام وبعض
المنظمات
وكانت رئيسه جورجيا تحدثت من الولايات
المتحده بخصوص هذا الامر وقالت بانها مع
هؤلاء
المحتجين بمطلبهم
وبانها لن تقبل بهذا القانون ولكن الان
نتابع عمليات واشتباكات ومحاولات اقتحام
الى البرلم الجورجي لمنع اقرار هذا
القانون هذه الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره
بين الشرطه والمحتجين